one of the questions that we've been
asking and that has been increasingly
answered has been
who knew and how widespread was the
foreknowledge that regardless of the
2020 election results failed former
president donald trump was going to
declare victory well over time we've
learned that more and more people were
aware that this was donald trump's plan
regardless of the outcome we've heard
now that a a drunken rudy jew allegedly
drunken rudy giuliani was suggesting
that he do it on election night but even
earlier than that in late october we now
have leaked audio a former trump adviser
and propagandist stephen bannon saying
the plan is to say that he won he might
not have won but the plan is to say that
he won and this is an explosive new
report from mother jones leaked audio
before election day bannon said trump
planned to falsely claim victory
bannon who at that point was no longer
officially working for trump knew the
plan if bannon knew it how many people
working for trump knew it it's very
clear that this was
obviously the plan that they had
that's our strategy he's going to
declare himself a winner we actually
have the leaked audio let's take a look
at it
the democrats
more of our people vote
early that count theirs voted mail and
so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage and trump's going to take
advantage of that's our strategy is a
declarance of a winner so when you wake
up wednesday morning
it's going to be a firestorm now
they had the same information we had
back in what
july
august september of 2020
i was telling you i was telling
everybody there's going to be this red
mirage
we expect
that
for a number of different reasons
including that democrats seem more
poised and more likely to vote by mail
that the early results may favor trump
more than the eventual results and that
over the course of the evening and
depending on which state because some
states stop counting at 10 pm or 11 p.m
and then start up again the next day
over the course of the night or the next
day
joe biden was going to gain momentum
we knew that they knew that as well
bannon admits it here he says there's
going to be the situation where our the
the voting trends are going to favor
trump early so trump's just going to go
out there and declare victory let's
listen to a little bit of that
um
again because it's so critical and that
we'll keep going
early that count theirs voted mail and
so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage and trump's going to take
advantage of that's our strategy he's
going to clear himself a winner so when
you wake up wednesday morning
it's going to be a firestorm
you're going to have antifa crazy the
media crazy now antifa did and diva did
nothing and antifa was a non-factor he's
wrong about that
courts are crazy and trump's gonna be
sitting there mocking tweeting you lose
i'm the winner i'm the king
and he'll be all over he'll be he'll be
going where's hunters hunter on a crack
pipe i mean no he'll be because then it
doesn't matter remember
here's the thing after then trump never
has to go to a voter again
he's going to fire ray the fbi director
before the scene and say [ __ ]
he's done his last election oh he's
going to be off the chase it'll be crazy
also
also if trump is if trump is losing
by 10 or 11 o'clock at night
it's going to be even crazier
no because he's going to sit right there
and say they stole it
and that's exactly what he did yeah
i agree i'm directing the attorney
general
to shut down all ballot places in all 50
states it's going to be enough he's not
going out easy if biden's winning
trump is going to do some crazy
and that is exactly what happened so
this is a leak the leak is relevant why
because it tells us that even people no
longer in trump's inner circle knew what
the plan was bannon was not working for
trump at that point and he knew exactly
what the plan was and he was right
that's from that's from the end of
october 2020 and that's exactly what
happened so it is a leak
but from what donald trump said publicly
it was clear since the summer of 2020
that he was going to claim to be the
winner one way or another he was saying
oh the this vote by mail stuff is all
fraud
i mean trump voted by mail sure but
that's trump other people are committing
fraud by voting by mail democrats black
people others so it was abundantly clear
that this was the plan
and bannon knew it and so the concerted
effort to carry this out as the strategy
was not a particularly closely held
secret bannon had of course more
specific knowledge bannon knew oh well
he's going to try to shut down ballots
trump tried to cease voting machines and
do all these different things but even
from what trump said publicly and even
from when trump was asked will you
accept the results if they say that
biden won and he said well i'd have to
see what what went on first this was
actually you know what's even more
interesting is
this was the plan for the 2016 election
as well in 2016
trump thought he was going to lose to
hillary
and he was going to say oh she won
because of fraud and whatever but
trump's going to move on with his life
and go back to being businessman trump
in fact if you really want to be
historically accurate trump started with
some of the election can't be trusted
stuff in 2012 claiming that barack
obama's victory over uh mitt romney
was you know the the there were problems
with the electoral college and all sorts
of different things trump wasn't
personally involved then in 20 remember
in 2016 when trump won in the electoral
college but lost the popular vote
he continues to say to this day
that he actually defeated hillary
clinton in the popular vote as well and
remember the claims of there were people
from massachusetts brought in buses to
new hampshire to help her
how people from massachusetts would be
registered to vote in new hampshire
continues to be beyond me it's never
been answered but trump still hasn't
admitted that the popular vote results
of 2016 were accurate so trump was going
to do this in 2016 he just so happened
to win electorally and then of course he
did it in 2020 and he told us that he
was going to do it so
stunning stuff that it seems everybody
knew that this was the plan
and now we have steve bannon
on the record
due to this leak
saying this was the plan all along
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman
all you have to do is pay five dollars
shipping